you guys ever been uh jumped by your
parents before no in what way [ __ ]
deserve this one though because we had
guests over right it was like my parents
friends from church and all this stuff
every Sunday night I get to play video
games I was like Mom can I go play a
game she goes no like when guests are
over like we have to like give them
attention all right if they're gone
guess what I could play my game well
they're chilling in the living room
right I was like you know what's funny
uh mom was saying like you guys are
overstaying you're welcome
oh holy [ __ ] my parents are denying no
no we didn't I was like yeah you did you
said it back there I'm like here we go
Sega Genesis so when they're saying bye
I'm standing there at the door saying
bye with my parents bye it was fun
having you cook as soon as the tour
closes I do one of these things because
they grab the back of my shirt I got
[ __ ] up so hard and I'm like but I
don't get to play video games you said
when they left I could blame it